I was watching, um, who's that really famous, uh,
comedy and also director guy in Japan.
He's always on that billboard and should be, Oh,
I saw him and he was on Japanese TV and he was reacting to this thing and he was
like LGBT stuff.
He had never seen such minimal reaction in my life.
He was like a bulldog just like that.
And then it cut to a guy in an onset giggling and he was like, nah.
And I was like, well, I think I know what he likes.
I don't care for this nonsense. Get that off. You know, it was just,
it was just funny.
Like Y Y there's like eight hosts and they refuse to take the camera off him.
It was just,
let's keep it like you see those at the point where he doesn't give a,
as long as he's on the show, people, it doesn't matter. It's just a non-branded.
So do you wanna explain to the audience who.
Well, talk to your beat? Takeshi has his cold cashews.
Casa is he's found a Turkish issues castle, and this one then comes from,
but originally he was a Japanese comedian and he's basically the reason why the
whole is crazy. All right. What are you doing?
I'm trying to talk about you. I drink this up anyway.
I mean, anyway, so yeah, so he was like,
he basically founded the whole Japanese comedy scene back in the seventies.
And he's the big reason why there's no comedy, not in Tokyo,
no jokes allowed. No. So in the soap he invented.
Okay. So,
so in, in, so the whole idea of like months I stand up comedy,
which is a very like Japanese form of standup comedy where it's like, you know,
one right. giggling and everything. It's like,
it's like SIM it's just shut off for a second. Just like,
it's basically like the whole it's called Monza, which is like,
there's usually one mic in the middle.
And two people standing in front of the one mic, you know,
doing a whole comedy routine.
And that was really big in all soccer or like in Kansai region and the standup
company. Well, yeah, it's a little bit different to just stand up comedy.
Cause a lot of standup comedy, at least in the West is usually like one person.
Yeah. Right.
Like it's just one person kind of telling an anecdote and then throwing a joke
within the anecdote. Like that's very general standup comedy,
but Monza is kind of like that.
But if you split the anecdote and the jokes into two different people,
so basically there's one guy who sets up the joke and then there's one guy froze
the punchline.
And then the guy who sets up the joke reacts to the joke and it's that whole
dynamic, is it like two person rocket go essentially. Yeah.
So like Rocco is more similar to Western standup company in that sense because
the doc who goes all about like telling an anecdote and then throwing it a
punchline at the end, Rutger just seems like style.
Up comedy hard mode because like imagine standup comedy,
but you have to sit in this one place and you can't move and you have limited
body movements. Right?
Exactly. But like Rocky goes like,
so ancient in Japan has been doing it since like, I even know how long,
but it's very, very often with comedy,
but basically the whole Munsey type of comedy really originally started in
like the fifties and sixties
[inaudible] but basically, yeah,
that was only really a scene that existed in Osaka.
And that's why like a lot of comedic I do,
I've noticed they all speak in concert dialect. All right. And, but uh,
how Kashi and his group, he was in a,
he was in a duo to beetle and he was basically the first like really
big Monza act to make it big in the Tokyo scene.
And it was because of his success that Monzo moved to Tokyo as
well and like the Tokyo area.
So that's why he's kind of just known as like a legend. Yeah.
He's basically the godfather of like Tokyo moms active
fireworks. Yeah. They put me in ghost to the show movie,
the dudes done everything. Like he like paints,
he directs he's like he developed his own game.
Was he in the original battle Royale as well? Of course.
That was one of his biggest roles. Yeah. He's pretty good on that.
He's really good. He's a great actor. Yeah. He's a very good,
I'm just eating chicken and broccoli and not achieving anything.
Where's your mom. Where's my mind.
I didn't realize he was a comedian that's because I already know him as like an
actor director. It's quite weird. Cause he's this comedian,
but he's also this incredibly stoic. Very, I noticed that. Yeah.
He's very like, not, I can't imagine him being a comedian because every,
in every film he's played, he's like super serious Briar. Right, right.
Like you watch, you watch like old,
like seventies footage of him while he was still in Subito and he's just the
most,
he was actually the guy who was like responsible for like telling the bot of the
joke. So he was always the like kind of on the ground, on the shark. Right.
So it's really weird now watching like ghost in the shell,
what's in this light hot face. Seriously? Yes I am the bad-ass in this. Yeah.
Just go around and be like, I'm the clown. It's just, I don't know.
I find it really cool that you like the movie likes a strong word.
I guess those. I can't wait, what movie are you talking about on the show?
Live action. I liked it as. I liked it.
If it wasn't a ghost in the show movie, why is it, Chris?
[inaudible] original animated film, but that's what I'm saying.
As a ghost in the shell movie, it was really bad, but so just a standalone,
like scifi movie. It was okay. I thought it was,
I literally walked out of the theater. Really? Yeah, because
I'm British of you because you're on board. I was just so bored.
I was really bored. It wasn't, I haven't watched it. It wasn't good. It,
she wasn't good, but he wasn't offensively bad. So what's the,
what's the premise of the film by the way for likes. I have no clue.
I know the shell, but I haven't, it's basically the first movie,
but with a bit of a twist, what, what what'd you know about ghost in the shell?
I've watched all of the standalone complex. Okay.
So you basically know the best parts of ghost in the shell.
Don't worry about the movie. It's just the [inaudible] complex,
smash it into hours and take away all the interesting things and.
You walk down and you've walked out of that. Yeah.
Well, how far in where you, you walked down,
she gets to like the first fight scene, like with the invisible guy. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. I got like 45 minutes before I realized I'm like,
I'm about to fall asleep now. But yeah,
that was probably the first 45 minutes was probably the best part of the movie.
Like these are comfortable, then the seats are comfortable.
Then the next second half, the way that the movie just ended,
where they were just kind of throwing in the whole cultural thing was just.
Scott, the Hanson was very well cast actress, but like not, not for that role.
I really respected scholar Jans and as an actress, but she just really, she,
it felt like she didn't care at all. It was like, no acting,
no one really gave a. It's like, I get you. You're supposed to be a cyborg,
but you know, put, put a little, she did that a bit too,
like a director when you're a robot right now. And she's like, say no more.
I got it. I understand. Yeah.
I don't remember much about that movie, which is,
I've only walked out of one movie in the cinemas and that was a dream.
I can pull [inaudible] cinemas.
Not walk out of that move. I wouldn't be like,
I'll be having a great time watching dragon boy.
Cause I watched the trailer and I was like, God, this looks like.
I'm going to go watch it.
And then it was so much more boring than I thought it wasn't even like,
it wasn't like the so bad that it was good level. It was just really bad.
I thought he was hilarious. I think it's hilarious. Wait, Chris,
if you walked out of a movie.
Theater, I've never been walked out of a movie theater.
This is the only one.
There was one that I just stopped caring really about like very close to what
life in general downsizing with David.
That's a terrible film is an airplane. I couldn't work out what was going on.
If it was a comedy, if it was a drama, it was just all over the place.
But like how many times have you been to the cinema by your side?
Uh, a lot. I used to go all the time. Yeah. I used to go like once a week. Yeah.
Cause like, if you're seeing a film of mates, like, huh, yeah.
Caught there for better or worse.
Even if your mates drag you to this Adam Sandler comedy.
I think whatever. I mean, okay. One, I would watch this Adam Sandler movie,
but uh, I mean, if I've planned to do it, it's an only in the evening.
And I want to admit that my evening was,
was tarnished by this film because I'm still going to enjoy the popcorn no
matter what, right? Like maybe I get a little nap in as well. My texts,
my sheep feed my mates, Tom buy some and it takes crispy. And like Chris,
when we collab in this film socks, dude.
I don't know. Like I, I rarely go to cinemas anyway.
So I love cinemas. I love them. Yeah. It's just something nice and relaxing.
And when you, especially in Japan or UK,
people just throw popcorn and it's a mess. So good Japan as well,
rarely films that I think, yeah. I need to go see this now.
Oh, I don't think that was any of the films I watched.
I just think like I want to go to the cinema because I want the Popsicle.
I just want the experience. And I liked the experience. I like sitting down.
I did. I, I haven't seen it. No. Well,
I mean it's special considering there's nothing out right now.
I thought it was nice to watch a movie. I'm not watching the demon slavery,
the Japanese.
Then I would go to the cinema so much more often because I love watching anime
movies. Cause I'm actually in tons of foreign films there.